you always want to outwork your
potential as hard as you believe you can
work you can work harder than that and I
had a summer where I played basketball
when I was like 10 or 11 years old and
yeah come playing and I don't score one
point the entire summer really not one
if you got to get up every single
morning remind yourself how hard you
need to work I need to choose a
different profession the motivation
watch a top 10 with believe nation
what's that belief nation that's Evan I
believe in you and this channel is
designed to be a part of your daily
success routine so let's get your
motivation to attend and get you
believing in you grab a snack and chew
in today's lessons from remain whoo I'm
from being a terrible basketball player
at age 10 and not being able to score a
single point in the summer league to
becoming one of the greatest NBA
basketball players of all time and
winning five NBA championships is Kobe
Bryant and here's my take on his top ten
rules a success vol 3
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one have a champions mentality when I
played one of the things that had to
learn is how to get the best out of my
teammates yeah and most people think
it's a simple thing you know passing the
ball you know that's not how you make
guys better you have to really affect
their behavior how do you do that
so yeah like I would tell guys you got
it back to backs you know I don't care
for in Miami I don't care if we're in a
great city of Chicago you can't go out
got your rest right back to back games
second bag gets right monday-tuesday you
play Monday and play in Tuesday guys I'm
gonna listen right you don't you're
right so few times said all right we'll
all go out go out together really I'll
drink with you
right but the next morning I'm banging
on your door at 5:00 in the morning
let's go they're not going where are we
going I'll hung out with you now you
come hang out with me this is what we do
all right let's go you're at the gym
we're working out right we hit the bus
we go to practice we play that night and
they're dead and they're dead they're
like lesson learned lesson learned take
them out once listen if you're gonna do
that do that but don't let that
compromise we're here to do right this
is why we're here this is why you're
here in the first place Yeah right and
if we're gonna win a championship we
have to have that championship mentalis
it work ethic that's it so you got to
show them low coke can do that and still
has the energy to get up and do this so
either I gotta meet that same energy or
I got to keep my but I'm gonna matter
early yeah rule number two
outwork your potential I think the best
way to prove your value is to work is to
learn is to absorb to be a sponge you
always want to outwork your potential
you know as hard as you believe you can
work you can work harder than that and
that's what I try to do when I first
came and lead but you know basketball is
such a direct competition sport that me
coming in at 17 I needed when like my
teammates would say you know I get hit
with an elbow right shack with it they
would elbow in practice and like
you know it big bad actor will come up
and say are you okay what the ma are you
okay how would you know it's so like I
always had that extra chip on my
shoulder so like every day I practice
for me was really trying to annihilate
everybody that was that I was playing
against because I wanted to prove you
don't need to babysit me like I'm fine
you know and and so as always that
competitive nature the work ethic and
curiosity because I asked a lot of
questions you know playing with Barnes
God I asked him a lot of questions Eddie
Jones who was great at chasing guards
off the screens and I didn't understand
how to do that I would sit with him
before practice after practice magic
James Worthy Kurt Rambis Kareem Abdul
all the Laker grades I would always sit
down and just asking questions about
certain games that I've studied growing
up what actually happened there what did
you filled it and why you know bird
tough to defend why cuz you look slow to
me I'm up like I'm missing something so
like tell me what I'm missing you know
what I think and so I would always ask
questions and try to learn as much as I
could rule number three learned from
failures you talk about this often and
we always talk about the fact that you
can learn a lot more from the failures
and you can from the successes and you
have to figure out where those landmines
are and then how to best avoid those or
put or help entrepreneurs and ourselves
included figure out the clues of where
those land mines are not that you're
going to avoid all of them but it's also
when you do step on one figure it out
okay how do you recuperate how do you
balance back and you know pick yourself
up rule number four be a long-term
thinker I had a summer oh I play
basketball when I was like 10 or 11
years old and a very prominent some
really good Philadelphia called the
Sunny Hill week my father played my
uncle played every like all-time great
stuff and Bo Chamberlain played in
league
or other Perlman role-playing we've
become playing and I don't score one
point the entire summer
really not one how old were you 11 10 11
you're playing against other 10 11
year-old sort and you didn't score once
not one were you in the game I was in a
game how'd you not score that was
terrible
really yeah that had a number years old
you were that awful I mean I you know
and I had these big knee pads on because
I'm wrong we fast I have socks all the
way up here and I had like the pod tops
pity yeah like skinny as hell and I
scored not a free throw not a nothing
not a lucky shot not a breakaway layup
zero points is that when you think the
mentality of hard work started to come
in for you at that age when you failed
so miserably I guess that's somewhere I
think that's when the idea of
understanding a long-term view became
important because I wasn't gonna catch
these kids in a week I wasn't gonna
catch him in a year right so that's why
I said down it's okay this is gonna take
some father alright we'd all want to
work on first
all right shooting all right let's knock
this out let's focus on this half a year
six months do nothing but shoot right
after that all right creating your own
shot and you focus so you start I
started creating a menu of things when I
came back the next summer I was a little
bit better right
many be like I've got my jump shot from
15 of God yeah I got my job in 15 I got
my three-point shot like just open shots
not miss open shots right and be able to
shoot it with speed because those kids
are so much more athletic yeah and then
the next time I came back as a little
better the summer came back it was a
little bit I scored yeah it wasn't much
but I scored 12 13 12 13 and then 14
came around back half of 13 14 years old
and then I was just killing everyone and
it happened in two years and I wasn't
expecting to happen in two years but it
did because what I had to do was work on
the basics and the fundamentals while
they relied on an athletics ISM and
their natural ability and because I
stick to the fundamentals it just caught
up to him and then my body you know my
knees stopped hurting I grew into my
frame and and then your athleticism
once you have the fundamental exactly
the hard work the mindset and you tack
on the 11
it was game Wow so from 13 you're good
average still that was good that was
good about about like the end of my 30
like right when I was turning 14 I
became best clear in the state a 14 or
14 so I'm from 12 to 14 you went from
scoring zero to being the best in the
state of all ages yep
rule number five find your passion we
talked about hard work all the time
mistake you know
man if you got to get up every single
morning remind yourself how hard you
need to work your I need to choose a
different profession you know because
that shouldn't be there is that I wake
up in the morning excited to get to it
you know if I'm not training I'm missing
it I'm not watching a game of bass I
miss it I you know there's no place I'd
rather be
and if you have that feeling then you're
truly doing with God has put you on this
earth to do rule number six challenge
yourself to grow you were quoted in on
CNBC as saying that you'd rather be
remembered for your role in
jump-starting tech companies than your
skills on the court can you talk to the
but what's that about it I think you
have to challenge yourself to evolve and
to grow and I think I couldn't think of
a better message for you know athletes
in particular because it's it's very
easy for us a athletes to kind of lose
ourselves and our identity by connecting
who we are to what we do and I think
that's a very dangerous zone to be in
right so it's uh it's common sense to me
to be able to say okay the next stage
I'm going after with the same intensity
same attention to detail the same
curiosity so of course I'd want to be
better at that than I was in my previous
career there's a pretty high bar there
you have you have enough energy left for
that orange I guess we're gonna find out
right I mean that best thing you know
you go for it and you do all you can you
learn as much as you can't you continue
to try to continue to improve you
continue to evolve the agency where you
are right you know 20 years from now you
can like to look at the mirror and say I
gave it my best shot and we did the best
we could and see where we end up rule
number seven keep going there's a quote
from
my English teachers alo Marian named mr.
Fisk
he had a great quote that said rest at
the end not in the middle and that's
something I always live by you know I'm
not gonna rest I'm gonna keep on pushing
now a lot of answers and I don't have
even questions that I don't have I'm
just going to keep going it's gonna keep
going and I'll figure these things out
as you go right and you just continue to
build that way so I try to live by that
all the time the rest at the end rest at
the end
rule number eight protect your dreams
dreams is a they should be pure I think
a lot of times we're born into this
world we actually wind up going
backwards and it seems like the more we
mature the more responsible our dreams
become and the more Governors we put on
ourselves and our ability to dream and
to reimagine and it's always a fight for
his parents and for you guys to make
sure that your dreams always stay pure
so it's not a matter of pushing beyond
the limitations of expectations it's
really a matter of protecting your
dreams protecting your imagination
that's really the key and when you do
that in the world just seems limitless
rule number nine be driven my journey
began in Philadelphia Pennsylvania at
the age of three years old my father
putting a basketball my hands and me
taking it from there
basketball was in Kobe's blood his dad
is Joe jellybean Brian he played eight
years in the NBA before uprooting his
family to take his career overseas as I
grew older we moved to Italy while Joe
was getting used to playing in Europe
his son was also making an adjustment in
Italy not many kids were perfecting a
jump shot but Kobe Bryant was soccer was
a big sport so he had goalposts
underneath the baskets on concrete
courts were kids used to play soccer all
day and I would be one of them and then
after soccer I'd stay there for another
three four or five hours his playing
basketball it was a different country
with a different language even though he
had his family he was essentially alone
so Kobe looked him and developed the
relentless drive to work on his game
[Applause]
when his family moved back to
Philadelphia that time spent alone on
the court paid off as Kobe announced his
arrival to the basketball
world he was the top high school player
in the country
breaking Wilt Chamberlain scoring
records becoming a celebrity at 16
Kobe's next step may have seen damn
Bish's but with his basketball pedigree
and work ethic it was an easy decision
[Music]
yeah and rule number 10 the last home
before a very special bonus clip is
achieve greatness
[Music]
I remember season one you said who is
this kid it's 20th season only various
careers in basketball
will not allow them to be what do you
want water any longer no one understand
what it takes to be great the force that
drives you to do what others don't
the sacrifice is made all with one
purpose in mind push yourself to become
better the extra seconds minutes hours
of work put into perfecting ones game
lifting yourself above the rest to make
sure your name will forever be
synonymous with one
greatness what does it take to be great
work at the combination drive takes
ability it takes its desire they learn
moves on muscle again turns it I think
it takes years of players relying on you
to take the big shot make the great play
you know do the things that bring
success to the team that's that's what
it's all about is getting out and
measure yourself against others and I
think that when you have an attitude
like that that's what I think that's
part of greatness the first time met
Kobe Kobe was just out of high school he
was out here poor workup and I've never
seen anyone work out this hard
this is coated I've never seen anybody
that prepared he was 17 years old and
was ready to play NBA basketball that's
that's pretty amazing
and I think Jerry West was the one who
said this he said I want this kid
because this kid had more talent than
anybody I have a plan for me right now
and he had a great team
just kidding would never take a night
off even if it wasn't calling well it
was always going to be trying to slay
the dragon if you don't have that type
of work ethic you don't get to enjoy the
benefits
[Applause]
now I've got a special bonus clip from
Kobe on how to be a good team player
that I think you're gonna really enjoy
but before that it's time for the
three-point landing questions time to
move from just watching another video to
actually taking action in your life or
your business and if you're feeling bold
leave your answers in the comments below
here we go question number one what is
your big dream number two how will you
protect it when people say that you
can't do it and number three how will
you keep going when you're not getting
results
when you're in this culture in our
society you can do some phenomenal
things individually but they'll never
reach their full potential unless you do
them collectively you have to figure out
how to do that and you know Phil Jackson
was great at then Phil he wouldn't just
coach the team or coach the game but
he'd read everything about every single
player we heard about your history how
you grew up how you were raised where we
were were you raised you know he'll read
every interview and he'll learn about
you and gives him a better understanding
of what's motivating you or what your
insecurities are right and then it just
helps him communicate with you better or
even push a button here if he needs to
there was a stretch and o3 where Shaq
was out with an injury and Phil called
me up to his office and said okay we
need you to really turn on the
afterburners to start scoring or you
have to win so I did and I wound up
scoring I think it was nine straight
games for 40-plus points nine straight -
three games and then Shaq comes back
second it's second to last game of that
and then Phil calls me up to his office
is cold okay I need you to dial it back
I'm like why I like well how about I
understand is because our goal is to win
a championship
mmm and we can get through the Western
Conference with you playing this way but
in the East you know we can dominate
them inside with Shaq in the post but if
you continue to do this we'll lose Shaq
will lose him his motivation his
exciting what triggers him right so I
need you to pull back so we can pull
Shaq forward for June and I just looked
at him like smart dude wow yeah this is
what smart dude man sigh pull pulled it
back see once was
yeah the most important work ever if you
had to think of one word that's most
important to you or that sums you Apple
that would be connect a little beacon
[Music]
if you want more Kobe check with the
first top 10 video ident under him the
link is right there next to me I think
you'll enjoy it continue to believe and
I'll see you there we have to make as
people as individuals so if you want to
be great at something you have to make
the inherit sacrifices that come along
with that family time